four lost teeth a special canine guest
and a powerful scene that got cut that's
just a taste of what brought the atom
project to the big screen we've got
audition stories deleted scenes and
improvised brilliance up ahead number
one it takes one to no one ryan reynolds
and walker scoble are an improvising
match made in heaven reynolds aka master
on set improviser was actually really
impressed by how well his pint-sized
co-star kept up with him really making
the part his own and whipping out
zingers reynolds even said the team
could throw that kid anything and he'd
deliver it perfectly walker was already
so much like reynolds naturally that
when they started working together
everything fell into place pretty easily
he's like my buddy by the end of it the
fact that walker was obsessed with
deadpool and could recite monologues
whenever reynolds asked him to he jumps
through the whole window and stuff and
he goes oh
oh this isn't gilbert's i am so sorry i
thought this was
well it definitely didn't hurt number
two we hoped there was a tooth fairy on
set i lost my tooth in one of the scenes
when we were filming it walker scobel
was filming one of his scenes with
reynolds and asked does everyone skip
leg day in the future then the actor
experienced an unexpected sensation and
when i did that my tongue flicked the
tooth off into the top of my mouth he
didn't lose just one though i didn't
spit it out on camera but i spit it out
right after we got off by the end of
filming scobel had four less teeth in
fact his very first day he said bye-bye
to a tooth that fell out while he was
eating on set number three it really was
built from the ground up adam's house in
the movie is nothing short of homie and
it was actually built in an old hockey
arena turned soundstage in vancouver
after the two months it took to build
the decorating team began sourcing tons
of pieces from craigslist etsy facebook
marketplace and local artists the team
went the extra mile creating an
environment around the house including
about 25 20 foot tall tree trunks it
could be seen through the windows of the
house
number four we all love a furry pal on
set because you can't wait to save
zip it
jennifer garner not only got to hang out
with her dog on set but she got to watch
her dazzle on screen as she played the
role of adam's dog in the atom project
garner's performance is great but birdie
the golden retriever manages to steal
the scene whenever she's on camera
number five in the midst of chaos it's
hard to determine direction that the car
was uh a weird day racing through the
forest trying to escape a ship with
unbelievable shooting powers is bound to
be chaotic but since they were actually
just sat in a car-like rig and filming
while safely stationary in the studio
the chaos came about for a different
reason since the actors weren't really
being jolted around in a car filming
required someone to yell turn so the
actors could all do it at the same time
but the trickier aspect to coordinate
was the direction it was so hard to time
every time they'd say like in turn we'd
all turn in a different direction this
was walker's favorite scene in the whole
movie to film
number six it's time for a tearjerker
the adam project gets us right in the
feels pretty early on in the movie when
we get to see older adam having a chat
with a younger version of his mom you
think you're being strong for him
and the problem with acting like you
have it all together is
he believes it this scene was actually
one of the major selling points for
garner when director sean levy was
proposing the project to her it was a
simple and quiet process on set garner
not even looking at the scene before
they filmed so she could just let the
conversation flow out it was so powerful
that it was just like we can't even look
at it we just have to go in and levy
knew they'd struck gold here some days
like that day at the bar you go and you
know when to shut up get out of the way
roll the cameras let the actors in the
writing do their thing no surprise that
from the very first test screener this
scene has been a favorite for audiences
every time
he loves you
well then he knows them
number seven how much gold ends up on
the cutting room floor while the scene
didn't make the final cut it was an
absolute favorite of the team so they do
hope to release it at some point down
the line the scene took place between
reynolds and mark ruffalo where
ruffalo's character said something along
the lines of look somewhere between the
villain that you think i am and the hero
that young you thinks i am there's the
real guy
i'm neither i'm just doing the best a
guy can it's a tear-jerker for sure so
why did they cut it while on its own it
was very special ultimately it didn't
quite fit the flow of the storytelling
luckily it's one that's likely going to
make it to our screens anyway number
eight making movies ain't what it used
to be zoe saldana was eager to join the
atom project when she first heard about
it but she did hesitate before deciding
for sure i took some time to to give
them an answer when filming began it was
only month seven of the pandemics so
saldona had some reservations but the
team went above and beyond to make sure
it would be a safe experience for
everyone involved that included a full
two-week quarantine in order to film for
just six days
the team was quarantined in a giant
gorgeous house on a lake in vancouver so
not a bad situation in the end what made
it all even weirder was the fact that
the actress only got to hang out with
reynolds and walker not even meeting
most of the other people in the movie on
set
number nine this kid was jumping through
hoops locker scobel is new to the biz so
when he first submitted his tape for the
part he didn't really expect to hear
anything back but then he got the chance
to read with a casting director that
went so well that he was invited back to
read with strong levy and then the
cherry on top he got the call to read
with ryan reynolds you flew planes you
had adventures and you fell in love
keeping his chill was tough as walker
was a major fan and literally watched
deadpool 4 times the night before donde
estella
which literally translates to i don't
bargain
the actor impressed the casting team at
one point in the process with an epic
rendition of a reynolds original that
was the first time i did it to someone
yet number 10 in hollywood no way but
maybe in vancouver it's possible somehow
this major film with all its sets and
tech was filmed in just four months with
the team having days to spare in the
schedule and extra cash left in the bank
more money for the cast party anyone
this was a high point of the
movie-making process for reynolds who
said the death of creativity comes when
there is too much money and too much
time with a cast and team like this it's
no surprise the atom project is such a
special movie full of heart and
fast-paced action which scene got you in
the feels